7h20 un incendie se déclarait à la
raffinerie de feyzin près de lyon
les images sont impressionnantes le 4
janvier 1966 la raffinerie de pétrole de
feyzin dans le rhône explose seulement
deux ans après sa mise en service
c'était il ya tout juste cinquante cinq
ans l'une après l'autre
quatre cuivres allait sauter à l'origine
du drame une fuite de propane
très vite un nuage de gaz s'échappent se
propage explose au contact d'une voiture
qui passait à côté de la raffinerie
il y avait une coulée est flamand peut
pas qu'il traversait la route quand même
la départementale j'ai pas détaillé
exactement et
évidemment tout le monde tournait sous
la route aussi bien sur l'autoroute
seule explosion est entendue à des
kilomètres à la ronde
des centaines d'habitations sont
détruites dans une école les pompiers
sont dépassés par les événements des
renforts arrivent deviennent grenoble et
marseille pendant plusieurs jours ils
tentent de maîtriser un incendie à
l'image de ce pompier choqué par ce
qu'il se passe je vois vous avez vers
les nombreux camarades je crois que il
ya des nombres des camarades sont à
l'hôpital je n'ai pas encore fait le
recensement m'ont piquée mais ymca ici
un piquet qui vient d'arriver il me
reste symbole hommes sur 12 je sais pas
où sont les autres sont peut-être à
l'hôpital sont peut-être nord
le bilan est lourd parmi les soldats du
feu sur 18 morts ont sondé pompiers il y
a aussi des dizaines de blessés certains
gravement
en témoigne ce photographe présent sur
les lieux de la catastrophe est brûlé au
deuxième degré au visage sur les mains
on était projeté à terre je me suis
roulé j'ai senti que j'avais une
casquette en nylon j'ai dit ça y est je
profite j'ai mis les mains sur la tête
et je me suis roulé dans la boue rouge
après trois jours de lutte
les pompiers finissent par éteindre
l'incendié autour de la raffinerie c'est
le vide
les maisons sont détruites
les rues sont vidés de leurs habitants
la commune de feyzin est devenue une
ville fantôme
on dit même qu'il y en a qui ont déjà
déménagé à la wii déménager parce qu'il
peut plus habiter pas pu éviter d'être
percutée ils reviendront au moc et bien
parce que ça ça pèsera déchire le temps
fait d'oublier
suite à ce drame une partie de la
raffinerie a été construite à l'écart
des habitations
aujourd'hui le site existe toujours mais
il est classé seveso
ce qui veut dire qu'il est surveillé en
raison du risque qu'il représente
[Musique]